a place of worship
suddenly resembled hell on earth the
suicide bomber blew himself up in the
middle of Friday prayers dozens were
killed in the explosion a second attack
mirrored the first twin suicide bombers
carried out an attack at another Sanaa
mosque first outside the building and
then inside an explosion outside they
used the chaos that followed to enter
the mosque in the middle of prayers then
they detonated the second bomb in the
middle of the worship the attacks came
at a time of extreme political
instability in Yemen the country is
seemingly on the brink of Civil War
president Abed Rabbo Mansour Hadi lost
control of a large part of Yemen back in
January when Shiite Houthi rebels
declared themselves the country's rulers
that forced hardy south to the port city
of Aden that was the site of deadly
fighting on Thursday between Hardee's
supporters and the rooty militias
Friday's bombings show the devastating
impact the country's political vacuum is
having and how the Islamic state
militant group is taking advantage of
the chaos